ahora veamos qué pasa con los
determinantes cuando multiplicamos una
de sus filas por un escalar entonces
tenemos una matriz la matriz a b
y por definición nosotros sabemos que
este determinante es igual a de menos bs
ok así lo definimos pero ahora nos
podemos preguntar qué pasa cuando
tenemos una matriz que tiene esta forma
aunque la primera fila se queda
exactamente igual a b pero la segunda
fila es muy parecida a la segunda fila
de esta matriz pero está multiplicada
por un escalar ok cada una de las
entradas las multiplicamos por una k
entonces tenemos que ser
y por aquí tenemos que por de y veamos
cuál es su determinante por definición
el determinante de esta matriz es tal
cual a por acá de que también lo podemos
escribir como acá a b - b porque hace
que también lo podemos escribir como que
a b c cierto bien entonces ya que
tenemos esto así podemos factorizar la
acá y lo que nos queda es que por a d
- abc y nada más viendo estas dos
cantidades uno a uno le salta a la vista
que esta cantidad es exactamente igual
a esta cantidad cierto entonces a final
de cuentas este determinante es igual a
que destaca por el determinante de esta
matriz por el determinante de a
ok entonces si en una matriz tomamos una
de las filas y la multiplicamos por un
escalar y después sacamos el
determinante este determinante es
exactamente igual a ese escalar o se
destaca por el determinante de la matriz
original
ok ahora no tenemos que nada más
multiplicamos una de las filas por el
escalar si multiplicamos toda la matriz
por el escalar como ésta es una matriz
de dos por dos entonces eso es
equivalente a multiplicar las dos filas
por el escalar y entonces estamos
haciendo este procedimiento dos veces y
aquí nos va a quedar cada porque a ver
digamos que tenemos una matriz la matriz
a que es igual o sorpresa a b
v
y multiplicamos toda la matriz por un
escalar ok eso es la matriz cada x
esta matriz es lo que obtenemos al
multiplicar cada una de las entradas
porque entonces que tenemos que a cada
vez que se
ahora si multiplicamos toda la matriz
por el escalar que entonces va a saber
que a la hora de sacar el determinante
bk
o sea si sacamos el determinante de acá
y acá ve que se está usando nuestra
definición va a saber que nos quedan
puros términos de acá al cuadrado por
otra cosa aquí usando la definición este
determinante es igual a que a por cade y
eso es que a cuadrada por ave y luego
tenemos que restar este por éste que es
cabe porque hace o sea que a cuadrada
por b c y ahora actualizamos la cal
cuadrada y nos queda que cuadrada x
- bc
y como este es el determinante de
nuestra matriz a entonces esto es igual
a que a cuadrada por el determinante de
la matriz a ok pero esto esto de que sea
k al cuadrado es sólo para matrices de 2
por 2 porque las matrices de 2 por 2
tienen dos filas ok hay que tener mucho
cuidado con eso para matrices de n por n
vas a ver más adelante que este escalar
entonces se eleva a la enésima potencia
porque tiene n filas entonces lo que uno
realmente tiene que recordar es que si
tienes una matriz y cambias o una sola
de las filas esas filas las multiplicas
por qué pero dejas exactamente igual al
resto de la matriz entonces el
determinante de esta nueva matriz es que
a veces el determinante de la matriz
anterior que estamos cambiando una sola
de las filas multiplicando la por acá
entonces vamos a ver más ejemplos vamos
a empezar por hacer lo mismo
para matrices de 3 x 3 y ya después nos
vamos al caso general
y bueno no tienes por qué multiplicar la
última fila de la matriz o sea nosotros
hicimos este ejemplo multiplicando la
última fila pero claramente funciona
exactamente igual si multiplicamos la
primera fila en lugar de la segunda si
no me crees intentarlo pero bueno más
con las matrices de 3 por 3 que tenemos
aquí nuestra matriz llamémosle a otra
vez estoy redefiniendo y este es una
matriz de 3 x 3
d efe
h y entonces empecemos sacando el
determinante de a vamos a escoger una
fila
recuerden que podemos escoger cualquier
fila o cualquier columna y sacar el
determinante usando esa fila pero pues
escogí esta y bueno de hecho escogí esta
fila porque es la fila a la que vamos a
multiplicar por un escalar entonces el
determinante de a usando esta fila es
igual a lo primero que tenemos que hacer
es recordar nuestro tablero de ajedrez
de signos se acuerdan aquí teníamos uno
más menos más menos más más - menos más
cierto entonces vamos a empezar por acá
y a esta entrada le toca este signo o
sea que empezamos con menos de por el
determinante de la sub matriz que nos
queda de quitar la fila que contiene b y
la columna que contiene osea el
determinante de bc h
v c h
y ahora tenemos que sumar
por el determinante de tachar la columna
y la fila y nos queda a cg
ah sí
y finalmente nos toca aún menos - efe
por el determinante de tachamos pillay
columna y nos queda a bg h
a ver
h ok vamos a hacer un poco más de
espacio
porque ahora vamos a definir otra
materia es la matriz prima y esta matriz
a primera ser muy parecida a nuestra
matriz a pero vamos a escoger esta fila
y la vamos a multiplicar por acá
qué hay de hecho escogimos esta pila
para sacar el determinante a lo largo de
esta fila porque eso va a simplificar
muchísimo nuestra prueba aunque entonces
multiplicamos esta fila porque y
entonces nos queda a ver que el resto de
la matriz va a ser exactamente igual
h pero esta fila es que a veces esta
fila aunque entonces que de acá
efe
ok notemos que esta nueva matriz para
nada se puede escribir como acá
ok esta matriz no es que si fuera acá a
estas dos filas también las tendríamos
que haber multiplicado por acá
y por eso la llamamos a prima porque se
parece mucho a a pero tampoco esa ok
entonces pues vamos a sacar su
determinante el determinante de a prima
y pues vamos a usar esta fila porque esa
es la pila que hace que las cuentas
salgan muy rápida entonces este
determinante es nos vamos a buscar el
signo nos toca un menos grave por el
determinante que nos queda de quitar la
fila y la columna que contiene una clave
aunque hay que es exactamente la misma
sub matriz que tenemos por acá cierto o
sea porque estamos en el mismo lugar y
las otras dos filas que no estamos
tachando son exactamente iguales
entonces estos dos determinantes son
idénticos ok
h y lo mismo pasa para el resto de la
pila y aquí nos toca más acá y más acá
y como estas dos filas son igualitas a
estas dos filas
entonces nos va a quedar el mismo
determinante acg y
y
y finalmente menos menos acá efe por el
determinante a bg h
a
así es que aquí tenemos algo muy bonito
porque como los determinantes son
iguales y aquí tenemos una f efe
y de i d y los signos además también son
igualitos lo cual tiene todo el sentido
del mundo porque esta matriz lo
obtuvimos a partir de ésta simplemente
multiplicando esta fila porque entonces
podemos factorizar la k de toda esta
cosa y nos queda entonces que esto es
igual a que por toda esta cosa que es
igual a esta cosa que es exactamente
igual al determinante de a
y determinante de
y listo el determinante de la matriz de
la cual tomamos una fila y la
multiplicamos porque es exactamente
igual acá veces el determinante de la
matriz original entonces esta cosa
funciona también para matrices de 3 por
3 y pues elegí la fila de en medio pero
sabemos todos que eso funciona para
cualquier fila y si no me cree también
puedes hacerlo tú por tu cuenta nada más
te recomiendo que ésta que es el
determinante a lo largo de la fila a la
cual vas a multiplicar porque porque
hace las cuentas mucho más sencillas
como acabamos de ver entonces ahora sí
ahora sí vamos al caso general porque
ahorita te ha dado puros ejemplos que no
son completamente particulares porque
aquí no tenemos números tenemos letras y
entonces estamos representando a todas
las matrices de 3 por 3 ya todas las
matrices de 2 por 2 pero se puede
demostrar para cualquier matriz de n por
n donde la dimensión n puede ser del
tamaño que se nos ocurra en cualquier
momento y como la prueba no es
nada enredos tenemos que hacerla
entonces tenemos nuestra matriz a que
ahora va a ser una matriz de n por n n
por n
y empezamos por la primera fila y en la
primera fila tenemos la entrada a 11 le
llamamos 11 porque está en la primera
fila y primera columna después tenemos
el 12 a 13 y así nos seguimos hasta que
llegamos al ah1n1 que hay de que está en
la primera fila y enésima columna y
luego tenemos la segunda fila y empieza
con el 21 y la siguiente entrada es el
22 y así nos seguimos hasta llegar al a
2n y nos vamos a saltar todas las filas
hasta llegar a la décima fila porque esa
es la fila a la que vamos a multiplicar
por el escalar que aunque hay entonces
empezamos a contar primeras filas en una
fila y así hasta que llegamos a la
décima fila y su centrada de la décima
fila son
uno de que está en la décima fila y
primera columna a dos
y 3 y así nos seguimos hasta llegar al
ad y n y luego hay muchas otras pilas
hasta que llegamos a la enésima fila a
n1 y n2 y n3
hasta llegar al a nm esta es la matriz
más general a la que puedes llegar
aunque con dimensión arbitraria y cada
una de sus entradas también las que se
te ocurran en el segundo muy bien
entonces ahora vamos a sacar el
determinante esta matriz está en general
el determinante b
vamos a usar esta fila que es la que
vamos a multiplicar por una escalar para
sacar el determinante de la matriz a ok
entonces empezamos por este coeficiente
a y 1 y tenemos que multiplicar esta
entrada por su signo pero ahí es donde
podríamos tener un problema porque ni
siquiera tenemos bien definido de qué
tamaño es la matriz ni sabemos cuál
exactamente es la pila y por qué lo
están tratando de hacer de la forma más
general posible entonces ni sabemos a
qué tablero de ajedrez de signos tenemos
que ir y menos sabemos cuál de las
entradas del tablero de ajedrez tenemos
que escoger
ok porque lo estamos haciendo la forma
más general posible así es que tenemos
tenemos que recurrir a nuestra función
destino y la función de signo para esta
entrada es simplemente menos 1 a la y
+ 1
esta cosa de aquí
de la entrada y como uno a la que
también le llamamos tablero de ajedrez
décimas tablero de
pérez
muy bien ahora ya que tenemos el signo
de la entrada
ahora tenemos que multiplicar por el
determinante de la sub matriz que nos
queda y quitar la fila en la que se
encuentra nuestra entrada y la columna
en la que se encuentra aunque yo sea
tachamos esta columna y esta fila y lo
que nos queda es tal cual la sub matriz
a y 1 ok
esta es una sub matriz de dimensión en
el -1 por n 1 que definimos hace algunos
vídeos exactamente como la sub matriz
que nos queda de eliminar la yesi martí
la y la primera columna
entonces sacamos su determinante y lo
multiplicamos por la entrada y por su
signo y listo ahora tenemos que hacer
eso con cada una de las entradas de esta
fila aunque entonces nos toca sumarle la
entrada a 2
multiplicada por el signo de la entrada
hay dos que está al cual menos uno
elevado a la potencia y más dos y
después multiplicarla por el
determinante de la sub matriz a y 2 que
es la sub matriz quita la décima fila y
la segunda columna y así seguimos
sumando muchísimo hasta que sumamos
todos los términos hasta que llegamos a
la entrada a y en la multiplicamos por
su signo que es menos 1 elevado a la y
más n encima potencia y multiplicamos
también por el determinante de la sub
matriz a&n ok entonces este es el
determinante de la matriz
pero resulta que se puede escribir de
una forma muchísimo más sencilla y lo
que vamos a hacer es usar esta anotación
para las sumas y aquí le ponemos el
término general que en este caso va a
ser a hijo te doy la cota va a
representar al 1 al 2 al 3 blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah hasta
llegar a la enésima columna aunque ella
sea la j va a variar desde que es igual
a 1 hasta que jota llega a tomar el
valor de n y luego éste se está
multiplicando por menos 1 a la potencia
y más n y esté a la potencia y más 2 y
esté a la potencia y más 1 entonces aquí
tenemos que elevarlo a la potencia y que
se queda igualito más la jota que varía
desde uno hasta n
y luego multiplicar por el determinante
de la sub matriz a y por la j que varía
desde 1 pasa por el 2 y por todos los
demás números hasta llegar al enésimo
entonces vamos a ponerlo por aquí una
jota y listo esta es la notación general
este símbolo lo que indica es que en
esta fórmula
vamos a ir sumando cada uno de estos
valores sustituyendo primero la jota por
un 1 y nos queda este término después le
sumamos este término sustituyendo a la
jota por un 2 y nos queda este término y
después sumándole este término
sustituyendo la jota por un 3 y así
hasta llegar a sustituir la jota por una
n ok
esta cosa de aquí
es equivalente a esta suma de términos
entonces ahora sí ya vayamos a lo que
íbamos vamos a tomar esta matriz y lo
vamos a dejar exactamente igual en todas
sus filas excepto en esta que la vamos a
multiplicar por una acá entonces en
lugar de volver a escribir déjame nada
más la copio
ok entonces lo que hice fue copiar todas
estas cosas y ponerlas por aquel que da
un poquito amontonado pero ni modo y lo
que vamos a hacer con esta copia de la
matriz es convertirla a otra matriz a la
matriz a prima que tiene una de sus
filas multiplicada por un escalar que de
hecho vamos a tomar esta fila para
multiplicar la por un escalar que o sea
que aquí en lugar de tener la entrada
1 vamos a tener la entrada que por ahí
uno y aquí la entrada que por ahí 2 y
aquí queda por hay 3 y que por ahí n y
ahora veamos cómo afecta esto a nuestro
determinante aunque aquí estamos sacando
el determinante de a prima y entonces
vamos a utilizar la misma fila que
usamos aquí arriba aunque esta fila
así es que nuestro primer término es
este término que ahora en lugar de ser a
y uno va a ser que por hay uno el signo
va a ser exactamente el mismo y la sub
matriz de la cual tenemos que sacar el
determinante también es exactamente
igual porque está su matriz lo que hace
es quitar esta fila que es la única fila
que modificamos de la matriz a ivana
también quita esta columna pero el
chiste es que todos estos términos
siguen siendo exactamente iguales ar
matriz que no tiene esta modificación
sobre esta pila ok entonces la sub
matriz ahí 1 primer en realidad está
exactamente igual a la sub matriz hay
una aunque entonces de hecho le vamos a
quitar la primera que entonces vamos con
la siguiente entrada
ahora en lugar de ser a 2 va a ser acá
por hay 2 el signo va a ser exactamente
el mismo la su matriz va a ser
exactamente igual entonces lo vamos a
dejar así y así nos seguimos con todos
los términos por aquí en el a y n en
lugar a tener ahí n vamos a tener cada
por ahí n que por ahí en el signo es el
mismo el determinante de la sub matriz
también es el mismo y listo ya
terminamos de calcular el determinante
de a prima y aquí lo que vamos a tener
es la suma desde que jota es igual a 1
hasta aquí cota es igual a n de menos 1
a la mascota por acá por ahí j por el
determinante de la sub matriz a prima y
j pero todos estos determinantes son
iguales como vimos en estos tres casos
entonces lo podemos quitar la primera y
aquí pasa algo curioso porque como está
cada no tiene nada que ver con la cota
entonces la podemos sacar de la suma que
es equivalente a factorizar la ok
entonces la ponemos por aquí
multiplicando toda la suma y le quitamos
d
y entonces lo que nos queda tanto en
esta suma como en los términos aquí
explícitos lo que tenemos es que el
determinante de a prima es igual a que a
veces el determinante de a cierto aquí
tenemos las caras si las factorizar
todas nos queda tal cual lo que teníamos
aquí arriba
aunque entonces el determinante de la
primera es que a veces el determinante
de siempre que a prima se haya obtenido
a partir de a modificando una sola fila
multiplicando esa fila por un escalar
acá
y quiero remarcarlo así como lo vimos al
principio del vídeo para las matrices de
2 x 2 esta matriz es muy distinta al
matriz que por a ok en el caso de k para
todas las filas se están multiplicando
por el ska lorca ok y su determinante su
determinante es por ejemplo si tenemos
aquí la matriz
11 hasta a 1 n
y por aquí estaba hasta la n 1 hasta la
n n gay si multiplicamos todas las filas
todas estas pilas las multiplicamos por
qué
ok que es a lo que nosotros llamamos acá
por a eso es equivalente a multiplicar
cada una de estas filas por el escalar
que aquí hay pero cada que multiplicamos
una de estas filas por el escalar acá si
le sacamos el determinante lo que nos
queda es el determinante de a por una
caja ok esto es sin nada nos hubiéramos
multiplicado la primera fila por acá ok
si ahora multiplicamos la segunda fila
por acá entonces aquí tenemos que volver
a multiplicar porque osea que nos queda
acá al cuadrado si después multiplicamos
la tercera fila porque entonces nos va a
quedar aquí que al cubo y así como son n
filas entonces aquí lo que nos va a
quedar es que a la enésima potencia por
el determinante de a ok entonces hay que
tener mucho ojo con eso